はいおはようございます
はいおはようございますさ爪社長です
あれから2ヶ月たちましたでヶ月ぐらいだよねそうだしたんですけどね3月に店舗の大
兵庫県呂勝ち取ってで早2ヶ月
世界大会でつながる遊戯王の大会の静岡の代表者が始まります増加中の購入店舗の中
から代表者の32出てきて
そのままでおじさんみんな日本大会に出るというわけ
東海代表として僕ともう一人後輩も一人店舗代表になってるんで
でここ最近ゲー遊行しかしてませんでした
今日の大会のパレード静岡じゃなくて浜松なのでちょっと今から遠出していきます今
ほらレシピ晒せよ世界2位のパターン
うっ
してね結果から人生ゲームのルーレットアビューでもムソ
注文書を買っていきますはいよし買ってきましたサイクルとトランプ付きポイント
テラー
か実釣しますまた電卓うっ
me
[音楽]
ブーバーつきました voodoo 思うんですけど ana 対人だから金ちゃん
ヌードルに ape た b でございます改造に付いたんですけども
1分間めちゃくちゃパティやっぱり泊時間になるパティキュラーよ
本当ですか
すごく美味しいよは0
ああああああああだめだわー
today ん
me
[音楽]
danejones
tjar
releasenote
ホテル10軒2分前になりましたん
頑張ってきたな
味もこれでコンプレベルプレイヤーてできるすべてのことないから大丈夫
やったらすまん
ではん
行ってきます
amaran
nara
pou dou dou
par
as 僕いい
ai
car
玉本当なんでドラで2枚で継承とさんはまくるさせてなく出さないの本葬れまあ1勝
できたのはかなりで降ったと思います増加県の代表を決める大会でまぁ
2回戦敗退ということでないけどまぁ静雄だけベッド16でございますそう言ったら声
が聞こえるな
まあ1回戦も実はすごい時間かかって
で行っ試合40分なんですよで3セットで日本を取ったら勝ちなんですけども
一回戦目の石 set 目で35分かかってて
多分その時点で僕はも出力切れててなんとか延長戦まで入って買ったんですけども
2回生までちょっと頭が回らなくてこれで僕の今年の
遊戯王の世界につながる大会は終わりでございます1年に1回しかないからね実は結構
ゴリーくれに友情やりまくってて練習とかめちゃくちゃせて結構やったんですけどもう
ちょっとね及ばずというか動きもあまり良くなかったし僕自身の集中力も切れちゃっ
たりしてて
あけちゃったんですけれどもあの体験にいる人たちはもうみんなめちゃくちゃ21
ちなんでその中
でも1勝できたというのはとても良かったのではないかなと思っております
僕みたいなコミュ障チックな人間にとってはそもそも楽しいというのはのでとても大事
なコミュニケーションツールになっております
非常に悔しいけどこれが今の僕の実力でございますちょっと最近を方ユーチューバーを
忘れてユディットだったんでちょっと youtube に戻りま
とてもいい経験ができたと思うので
来年に生かそうと思いますじゃ
[音楽]